[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes
brought to you by spectator tv and
broadcast on thursday july 8th
i'm cindy you the spectators broadcast
editor on this week's show
masks and social distancing will be
scrapped indoor venues will open to full
capacity
and mass events will be allowed on july
19th but is the roadmap
as irreversible as the prime minister
has in the past suggested
we'll also be taking a look at china's
influence in the uk
specifically over universities
specifically over cambridge university
has it been bought by chinese money and
finally
are the culture wars ruining art i'll be
hearing about what it's like to be
cancelled and uncancelled from the
artist's jazz divorce
and the new lengths that some novelists
are going to to prevent that from
happening to them
all that to come in the next hour before
we get going if you enjoy what we do on
spectator tv then subscribe to our
youtube channel for free
click the button at the bottom of this
video and then tap the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode
and if you want to subscribe to the
magazine you can get 12 weeks of the
spectator in print and online for just
12 pounds
plus we'll give you a 20 pound amazon
voucher completely free
just go to spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer to take it up
now first all domestic covered
restrictions will go on july 19th
but as james forsyth writes in this
week's magazine it will not be the
triumphant moment that many expected
he joins me now alongside the
spectator's assistant editor
isabel hartman james why is the
government so concerned
i think at the beginning of may there
was a hope that
when the relaxation restrictions came it
would come with cases at a very low
level
and it would be clearly kind of fairly
risk-free
i think what you're seeing now because
of a delta variant is a very different
situation
where the government is essentially
relaxing the restrictions because
they calculate that this is the least
worst moment
to do so if you were to delay relaxing
these restrictions by
another month for example then the exit
wave would crash into the beginning of
the school year
further disrupting um children's
education uh
and the university students going back
to their halls of residence and all of
that
uh then if you were to wait until all
adults have been double vaccinated a
case made by some people
you know that would be that won't happen
until mid-september you then add on a
fortnight for immunity to build
and you're looking to be unlocking at
the beginning of october
so the peak of the exit wave would
coincide with the beginnings of the
winter pressures on the nhs so
i think it is a risk but a risk that
they calculate is one
worth taking to unlock now but i think
it's it's certainly going to be a more
nervy experience than people expected
uh when uh when the
uh country seemed very on top of the
so-called kentish variant
but delta variant has definitely changed
the calculations and james as you point
out in your political column
and as kiyosama pointed out earlier this
week you know this might not be a sum of
freedom because a lot of people are
going to be getting pinged by their nhs
app or
followed up by test and trace as well do
you think that the government is
managing
expectations on that front well enough i
always speak to my friends and they
don't think that they're going to want
to be pin pinged
yeah i think there has been a shift from
ministers in recent days there was a
obviously a build up to um the
announcements for
freedom day uh as it was uh popularly
being called and i think a desire to
excite conservative mps and to give uh
brits the sort of feel-good factor
um of a summer that they could actually
enjoy
james is one way to manage expectations
just for the prime minister to set out
as he has done for infections
exactly how many hospitalizations and
deaths we might expect
so that when those things come around
you know people already have those
numbers in their minds and think
actually this is just you know part and
parcel of the link being
hospitalizations and
infections being weakened but not being
broken
yeah i think you know something strange
that the government is so happy to bandy
about case numbers boris johnson's press
conference on monday talking about
possibly fifty thousand cases and rising
on july the 19th
sergio javid talking about the case rate
getting into a hundred thousand cases a
day
and but they're not saying what they
think that leads to in terms of
hospitalizations
and and pressures on the nhs i mean that
is that is an
odd fact i mean that is going to make
people skeptical like well
you do you have those numbers what do
those numbers say and i mean i think
that is something the government
is gonna have to address i mean the
other question here is
you know do does the pressure on
hospitals even if it doesn't overwhelm
hospitals
does it lead to uh elective surgery
being cancelled
and does this lead to the nhs waiting
list
already five million strong getting even
bigger because i think one of the big
things we're gonna
that we're gonna turn to is you know in
the autumn i think very quickly the
debate is gonna turn into a backlog
in the nhs the backlogs in education the
criminal justice system
so you know is this summer going to
essentially
increase that battle in the nhs quite
substantially because hospitals will be
able to
the only way software will be able to
deal with the situation is by basically
concentrating solely on kovic
i mean that is one of the risks i think
you also see
again not explicitly but you also see in
some of the government's actions
an expectation of when they think the
tide will turn i think it's very telling
that for example
the fact that people who are double
vaccinated will not need to
self-isolate on coming into contact with
someone with covert but that change
comes in on
august the 16th i think that suggests
that that is when they the government
think that the number of new cases is
going to begin to seriously ebb
that that date in the middle of august
israel let's talk about that backlog
because this
is a topic of a new podcast series
you've got with the spectator
called building back can you tell us
about you know how severe this problem
of backlogs
are in various sectors and what your
podcast series is going to be looking at
yes thank you cindy so the uh the first
episode of that podcast is on the nhs
backlog
because it's one of the the most
striking problems to have come out of
this pandemic while politicians say that
they protected the nhs and stopped it
from being
overwhelmed that is only true to a very
limited extent
and a lot of other services elective
treatment
surgery particularly around cancer were
put on hold in the first lockdown
and still have still not recovered
because
uh the beds in icu for instance for
clover patients require anesthetists and
people to be diverted from other
disciplines and so
nhs services haven't been able to run at
full capacity to treat illnesses that
aren't covered for a long time
now nhs waiting lists were going up
anyway before the pandemic there was
already an issue with people waiting
for longer and there being more people
waiting on those lists as well
but this is obviously exacerbated it to
an extraordinary extent so
uh the official figures are that five
million people are waiting but sajid
javid
who's been coming out with some pretty
terrifying figures generally
since taking over as health secretary
has also said that there may be
seven million more people who hadn't got
into the nhs over the past year in a bit
and
uh the worries of those who are waiting
list experts is that those people will
have waited for longer to be diagnosed
obviously when you wait for treatment
with something like cancer
your condition doesn't just stay static
it can often
get much worse and be harder to treat
and spread to other parts of the body
um and so there is this big backlogger
across the country and
the nhs also actually having a summer
crisis at the moment with with a lot of
cases
of covid a lot of cases of long covid um
that are being treated as well well just
on that is about you know sergio java's
new health secretary and he's come out
with a seven million figure but it
suggests that the government was sitting
on it before
so it almost raises the question of why
wasn't anyone told about this earlier in
the pandemic
now i'm i'm not sure that's fair because
having spoken to hospital chief
executives i think they have genuinely
been trying to work
out how many people they didn't have
who were coming down the line and i know
that the behind the scenes
talks between number 10 and the treasury
and the nhs and individual
hospital trusts have been very much
trying to work
out uh how many people there are that's
one of the reasons why we haven't seen a
detailed plan
uh a detailed funding plan on how to
deal with the backlog which is what
we're going to need for the next few
years but to be fair to
uh ministers they they have been working
really hard to try to work out the scale
of that but
i agree that it is strange that satya
javid managed to to get those numbers
presented to him quite so quickly after
becoming health secretary
and james as well as healthcare you know
you mentioned your column that's
education the criminal justice system
all these other areas but you identify
healthcare as the most
politically dangerous area for the
tories not to get on top of why is that
i think first of all because in
whitehall the view is that one in four
households will have someone on the nhs
waiting list by the autumn and that is
an
awful lot of people affected that is
more than will be affected
by the backlog in education uh i think
the other point is the tories are going
to turn themselves into the kind of high
priests of a national religion if you
think back from the killing
vote leave let's spend let's not send
the money to brussels that spend 250
million on the nhs instead
to the tory campaign in 2019 they have
worked to try and persuade people that
the kind of the nhs is safe in their
hands
if you end up with a really big uh nhs
waiting list
it opens up a front for kierstarma to
attack and say look
they say they're different but they're
really the same old tourists you can't
trust some of the nhs
is your nhs uh better or worse than it
was four years ago is it better or worse
than it was when the tories came to
power
i think you'll see kierstarma being able
to make a lot of that argument in the
autumn if they
can't get on top of the backlog i was
very struck talking to a
cabinet minister last week when they
they think that the political
difficulties of dealing with these
backlogs because
there are both financial and capacity
constraints how quickly you can clear
them
are going to be so bad that um labour
will end up going back ahead in the
polls
so that's quite serious isabel do you
think that actually the urgency of the
pandemic has actually been
a reverse honeymoon period for the
tories in that you know
now that normal politics is returning
they might have a harder time with it
yeah i think domestic problems that
they've they've had brewing for
a long time even before boris johnson's
premiership actually
are going to start coming home to roost
and they've got a lot of
weakness in government departments so
sadja javid is obviously a
a good senior appointment to take over
from matt hancock as health secretary
you need someone who who's got all the
political capital available and all the
experience available but
if you go across to the education
department for instance
gavin williamson is is not a powerful
figure within westminster and perhaps he
will get reshuffled
when there is a reshuffle but uh but
boris johnson certainly needs to
strengthen his
his top team to be able to brace
themselves against what's coming over
the next few months
james and as well thank you for joining
spectator tv
now throughout this entire pandemic
we've been following the science
but what about other experts
philosophers for example
could tell us whether lockdown is really
the moral way forward and how to balance
the costs to livelihoods and lives
as we turn towards the next phase of the
pandemic these questions
should be coming to the fore and thought
about by more people than just
epidemiologists so today i'm joined by
two colleagues from the university of
oxford
professor julian savulescu is director
and professor dominique wilkinson is the
medical director
at the uhiro center for practical ethics
julian to start
despite his hesitancy to reopen the
prime minister has in the past
said that the measures will be
irreversible is he right to say that
well it definitely can't be irreversible
um we could get a highly virulent strain
that kills more
people than earlier strain so it is
possible that we would have to lock down
again
but but i think what the biggest problem
in this pandemic so far
is that the the metrics have been all
wrong
uh we've been just looking at deaths and
and
the death of a hundred year old counts
the same as the death of a ten year old
uh and i personally hope i die at a
hundred and not at 57
because it's it's much worse to die at
57. so i think we need to start to
to to take a more mature approach to how
we measure
the impact of of any surge or any um
any flare-up uh and and we have to
to to not have this almost maniacal
obsession with covert deaths as the only
measure
you know i've seen estimates that
roughly as many people
will die as the result of lockdown
measures from non-covert related causes
as we'll die from covert related
causes so i think we need to start
thinking in a more balanced way
about the severity of of these pandemics
the nhs is one of the most underfunded
health systems in the world or in the in
the western world
and you know it regularly run runs up
against the limit in a non-covet related
year
so i think we need more money injected
into healthcare
rather than restricting people to their
homes
living in terror of going outside and
wearing masks continuously
and i think we need to think more
selectively about how
we we protect the vulnerable
while also allowing those who are not at
risk
and and people under the age of 30
really you know are not at a substantial
risk from covert and yet they've borne
the brunt of
of all of these restrictions and will
continue to so i think another measure
that we should be taking is more select
selective
restriction uh of of um movement and
freedoms
uh to those who it will benefit rather
than
uh you know punishing the the younger
generations who've already paid too high
a price for this
well dominic what do you think of
julian's claim that the death of a
hundred-year-old is much less sad than
the death of a 57 year old
that seems to be suggesting that lives
have different values and there's
something that
some lockdown skeptics in the uk have
got into trouble for saying
well i think obviously life has value to
everybody who who who wishes to to stay
alive but we all of us have reason
uh if we if we're living well to want to
lie
to live for longer so i think
generally when we're thinking about
public health interventions we should
think
not solely about saving lives but also
about how long we might save lives for
and also how well people will live and
of course we're used to thinking about
that when we're thinking about quality
adjusted life years
and and working out which drugs will we
fund in our
in our health system which interventions
we do need to think in a sensible
uh and similar way about
the costs and benefits of interventions
uh in a pandemic but you kind of scared
of the question there do you think that
we should be valuing younger lives more
than older lives
well it so i i think when we're thinking
about the the costs of the pandemic
uh the costs to young people can be
great because they'll be born for a very
long period of time
somebody who might survive for a short
period of time
uh it's it's much
less bad for them to die than somebody
who might die
for example a young person or a young
pregnant woman
uh who might have had many years of life
so
all deaths are not equal and again
that's a problem with
thinking purely in terms of numbers of
deaths so the
the british philosopher uh and
bioethicist john harris once proposed a
fair innings
uh of of three score and ten um and and
this
i think he's moved away from this view
now that he's over 70.
uh but this this was also picked up by
an american philosopher dan callahan
in a book called setting limits that you
know we should set a reasonable lifespan
for people
uh and after that point we we shouldn't
be investing
large amounts of resources he was
talking about individuals in prolonging
their lives
this is not my view um but it was
callaghan's view
uh and and we've we've basically stopped
the world and the economy
uh in many cases to to to save the lives
of people who are
you know way beyond the sorts of limits
that harrison callahan were talking
about
so yeah i mean i think if you look at
at the average numbers of years life
lost
from covid it's 10 years or more so it's
not simply the cases is sometimes
claimed
uh that those who've died from covid
have have all been those who
who would otherwise have died within the
next winter from flu for example so i
think
it's important to recognize that that
covet has come at the cost of both lives
and life years and quality of life
so but those are all the things that we
should be focusing on
how do you get all of those metrics
together because you know philosophers
in the past have tried to come up with
um algorithms or equations that kind of
add different parts together and end up
with sort of
pseudo i guess pseudoscientific result
of
morality but how do you measure all of
that do you add up tally up the amount
of years lost
depending on average life expectancy and
then just hope the best
from there yeah i mean there are many
different metrics for example there's
excess mortality that that you could
look at how how much worse are we doing
overall compared to
previous years and i think this is a
very
very important question and obviously
the government has settled on a very
simple metric of deaths because people
understand that it's a number
you know they can all grasp but it's
extremely crude
and and and that's only covert deaths so
i think we need to start to think about
how we can convey
and measure the severity in in a more
meaningful way as we go forwards
now you know we probably did as well as
we can we could have done you know
everyone was operating you know in huge
pressures with inadequate information
and you know i i think it's probably
right to take death as your your metric
but come the next pandemic i think we
need to think you know
in a in a more nuanced way about how
we're measuring the impacts
of these kinds of things well julian
before we even get to the next pandemic
if you were
advising the government from you know
the sort of ethical perspective
of when to reintroduce restrictions if
we have to later this year
you know if you don't think death is a
good measure
understandably for emergency reasons it
might be what would you
be advising the government be looking at
well i'd be advising them if if
the pressure on the health system was
such that
people under the age of 70 or 75 who
needed
life-saving uh interventions were not
getting them
so that would be my my metric that's a
simple one
um but i wonder what dominic would say
because he's at the cold face of working
in the hospital
yeah so so i think here we agree uh
actually the although there's lots of
questions about
how many deaths should we accept if we
want to to return to normal life i think
that's a mistake i think the
the crucial thing is is uh can our
health system
cope that's in fact what's triggered uh
many of the restrictions in liberty that
our health system was in danger of
buckling
with huge flow on consequences for
um people both with covet and with other
non-coveted illnesses people who
wouldn't be able to get into hospital
with their heart attack or stroke or
wouldn't be able to get treatment for
their cancer so i think that
is the the relevant trigger point and
the reason
potentially for unlocking now is because
in the short term
it looks like that isn't a pressing
danger and finally julian dominic i
wanted to get your opinion on this
question which is that do you think the
pandemic
has made society trend towards more
towards the collective
in the near future as well so whether
it's the next global health
threat or something else we're now more
likely to be collective in our morality
we're now likely to be caring more about
other people in in our ethical concerns
than just than what we were before
well i mean i i think in these sorts of
debates it's very easy to
to extrapolate from you and your friends
to how everyone thinks so
maybe we are thinking more collectively
in this group
but i'm i i know talking to taxi drivers
and people
out there there are many people who have
been really hurt by
the lockdowns and the policies who are
very disaffected
so i don't think i could generalize to
how people will think i think many
people will be skeptical
about the information that they've been
provided with about the level of of
protection and care
that's been exercised about the
competence of government
uh i think you know it may be that many
people are disaffected
um so i i think it's it's very difficult
to make generalizations
like that but dominic you probably see
more ordinary people than me
yeah i i don't know it i think
we're not going to know for some time
what what the the lasting changes in
society and societal attitudes
are going to be from this pandemic but i
think one vector that's very significant
is global awareness uh
of of the vulnerability and the
fragility of our
of our communities of our health i think
many people
in the general public have been
surprised by how suddenly and
dramatically
their lives could change and of course
that that highlights
the the the great significance of some
potential threats and they include
further viruses but they also include
things like antibiotic resistance which
and uh is not only remains a kind of
potential
enormous threat around the corner but
actually has been exacerbated by some of
the
antibiotic used during the pandemic so
so i think
that sensitivity of weak
and awareness of how our individual
well-being is connected to the
well-being of not only those within our
community
but also those around the world i think
that
is a potentially lasting change i think
that
that one i mean one important lesson i
hope
is that i mean some some very
esteemed peoples like for example martin
reese the the
former president of the royal society
and astronomer royal
and others have have estimated there's a
50 chance we won't make it through this
century
uh and one of the causes of that will be
biologically
as a species and one of the causes of
that will be biological weapons
um or could be biological weapons and
and this and and
sars kov2 is is actually
in the big scheme of things a very mild
infection
it's nothing like smallpox the mortality
is somewhere between 0.03
to 0.3 uh and it's completely ripped
apart the world
it kills people 90 of them over the age
of 65.
it's nothing like smallpox it's not as
bad as tb
so this is just a trial run for
what could happen and we haven't done
very well uh
and the big picture for me is as dominic
says the fragility but
you better believe that this is not as
bad as it can get
uh and you know in in within 10 years
tens of thousands of people will be able
to make something like sarsko v2 or even
smallpox in a backyard laboratory
uh and release it uh you know as as a
as a malevolent act so you know we we
are really
you know on the brink even though we
don't and this has been really a wake-up
call to just
how fragile our existence is um so we
really need to start thinking about how
to prepare
for something much worse than this well
on that cheerful note dominic and julian
thanks very much
remember we have a special subscription
offer for viewers
if you subscribe to the magazine you can
get 12 weeks off the spectator
in print and online for just 12 pounds
plus we'll give you a 20 pound amazon
voucher completely free
now to the cover story of this week's
magazine journalist ian williams takes a
detailed look
at the cosy relationship between
cambridge university and the chinese
communist party
arguing that china has bought the
university to make his case
he joins the show now and we're also
joined by professor kerry brown director
of the lao china institute
at king's college london ian can you
explain what's happened
between cambridge and china yeah the
biggest project that
cambridge has out the international
project is a joint venture with nat with
nanjing
municipal authority in china which is
described as a smart
cities research center this was signed
in 2019
and has been valued by cambridge at 10
million pounds
now this is we are told
um research into the bold new technology
that will make cities more livable going
forward
sensors that will determine everything
from when your rubbish needs to be
cleared through to the flow of traffic
now certainly this may happen and it may
well be
that the brave urban centers of the
future are fully connected but
in chinese terms smart cities
are called safe cities and it's
inextricably linked with surveillance
technology
security and repression epitomized by
what's happening in xinjiang
and to me it's incredibly naive that
cambridge can
pursue what is the biggest project of
its type and the only one which has its
name
um in a technology which in the chinese
terms
is contributing to the surveillance
state and
to repression in that country um this
the contract itself was celebrated by
the oversight
people at cambridge whose job it is to
to examine these sorts of deals as just
the sort of
relationship that china that uh
cambridge needed going forward now that
britain has left the european
union and there seemed to be no serious
discussion
about how this technology could be
contained
and how technology which is clearly dual
use
um could be prevented from being used
repressively
as it has been quite widely within china
kerry what do you think is all of this
above board or not
well the first thing i have to say is
i'm a graduate at cambridge so
i have to declare that interest the
second is i have known
um the institute at jesus college and
i've spoken there
and i've known peter nolan for 25 years
um and his uh interest in
you know kind of china's politics and
his you know kind of
sympathy i suppose is uh not a new thing
it's been around for 25 years
i mean cambridge university's governance
has been
highly secretive for 700 years
and i have to say there's one
organization on the planet that is more
opaque than the communist party of china
that's cambridge university uh so i mean
i think that's one of the issues
the second other associated issue is
that
i i think you know it's right for ian to
raise these concerns
um the issue really though is that of
course british universities
generally and for quite some time have
needed to be very entrepreneurial the
london school of
economics got into terrible problems
with gaddafi in the you know kind of
early 2000s and
one of the issues is on the one hand we
have a government that tells us you know
go
raise money be entrepreneurial
post-brexit on the other
we are kind of told we'll be terribly
careful with the world's second biggest
economy even though there may be very
important alignments
those alignments are really really
crucial too public health
environment these are not issues where
china needs to be opaque or anyone needs
to be opaque because we all seem to now
know what we're dealing with
i think it's really important to
maintain lines of engagement
i look upon it as you know it's probably
problematic that you might have parts of
british universities
that need to have engagement and
dialogue with parts of the chinese
entity and state that are problematic
but i think that engagement needs to go
ahead
and i think that it is relatively low
risk the issue is that jesus college
crew one of these
china centers is doing engagement in an
area which is difficult
it's well observed it's being watched by
journalists and observers
and i don't see it as quite as grave an
issue as buying a whole university
the final thing i have to say is that um
the xinjiang issue
is a serious and important issue i don't
deny that
that is not however the situation in
other areas of china the problem really
is that
for the chinese middle class who are
absolutely crucial to the xi jinping
leadership
their views too are often public opinion
as far as we can see from what evidence
anecdotally and also
in terms of uh you know kind of surveys
we're pretty supportive of maybe even
more extreme positions
and so we can't just play one
organization for this
the communist party of china can take
some of the flat for sure and should
take some of the flat
but it is not as simple as just saying
that organization
is the only problem it's much more
complicated
well there's a lot to impact there
carrie because you touched on a lot of
the things that i want to touch on in
this conversation
in general ian just just starting with
one of the factors which is that
surely some engagement with china
especially on a research basis
has to be done for one there are some
research that is just
a bit more innocuous for example climate
you mentioned this renewable energies
institute that cambridge also has a
partnership with china on
and especially on a material basis you
know if the government is going to be
cutting research funding
uh and stephen tube the vice chancellor
of cambridge himself
has campaigned to not uh get against
these research cuts then you know they
got to get their money somewhere
for our stem subjects so what do you say
to that
they have but i think it needs to be
transparent and it needs to be open
and it needs to be debated and as kerry
pointed out
too often and we're seeing this with
cambridge that this has not been the
case
and they preferred to sweep any to avoid
any sort of discussion or sweep these
sort of arguments under the table
i mean two examples i used in the
article
was the engineering department at
cambridge that signed this
quantum computer deal with tencent
the owner of wechat and
the blurb on the engineering department
website i checked it it was not only
the termed in ways which would
uh justify from a wechat point of view
but it was lifted from the wechat
website website
um likewise i think with the institutes
at jesus college when they were first
set up
which was in the wake of the the golden
era of
cameron and osborne which was you know
very much like a starting gun
for everyone to go chasing after chinese
money almost no
no questions asked the language on their
websites was also lifted almost word for
word
from communist party documentation from
from from propaganda
and i do accept that there is the need
for engagement but i think it has to be
done
in an open and transparent way i mean
the example i i
made in the piece um the sustainability
leadership center in cambridge the
refurbishment of the old post office
now this is a very important issue
renewable energy
but half of the almost 13 million pound
cost of that refurbishment is being met
by a chinese entrepreneur
now nowhere in the china in the
literature put forward by cambridge
the glowing description of this
particular character
does it mention that he's a member of
the chinese parliament
and a communist party advisory group and
indeed when
the deal was being signed on this center
this same body the npc was busy passing
a law
that effectively shut down the remnants
of democracy in hong kong
and surely we should know that that
we're not
that cambridge is not just getting money
from a billionaire
who is into renewable energy which is
you know
commendable though that might be but it
is also accepting money from somebody
who is a party
to repression in hong kong and i think
if that were known
a lot of people may feel rather less
comfortable about it
kerry ian mentions you know
entrepreneurs and companies like tencent
who are
primarily primarily tech companies and
wechat is a social media platform
as well as the ccp do you think that any
money that comes from china
can ever be clean in the way that we
would like it to be given
just how interventionist the communist
party is in
everyday life in china i mean
money coming from anywhere is going to
be problematic what's clean money i mean
that's an interesting concept to me
it must be a relative term there must be
more money that's cleaner cleaner than
others
well um i mean if you so if you say
uh that china is problematic because of
lack of transparency
uh because of entrepreneurs being deeply
linked to the
uh party state um and i mean that's true
i mean we cannot
deny that you know there are links
although i think they're complicated and
not
straightforward you then have to say
okay we don't deal with china period you
can't have an intermediary position you
either deal or you don't deal
and my point is that um
maybe the the the only big disagreement
i have with ian's analysis i suppose is
that
i don't think we can do much about the
problem there china has
many other places to look at and many
other things to do
it is on its way to being the world's
biggest economy and
that looks most unlikely not to stop for
us it's going to be a really interesting
question about
organizations like cambridge university
that prioritize
rightly uh the freedom of their
associated institutions colleges and
different departments
who will if if we want the level of
transparency that the is alluding to
they're going to have to radically
exchange the way that they communicate
with each other the way that they deal
with each other
cambridge university as an institution
cannot really do much about what a
college institution like the china
center does
that's its economy that's it's a freedom
that's what's been the case for 700
years
and so if you want to change that you
have to change the governance of
cambridge university to have that
openness the problem is here it's not
really in china on that
at that level and i don't really know
how you do that because their autonomy
is really
important for themselves the issue that
china has raised
is really more for us to deal with
within ourselves
and it's going to be a very very tough
thing because in essence what you're
going to end up arguing is
we are needing to be more subject to
regulations and rules
and government interference because of
china
which is a very interesting thing that
china the great surveillance
problem means that we then surveil
ourselves much more well that's win-win
for china i guess
ian what do you think um well i i think
it just needs more rigorous
oversight i don't necessarily would
characterize
it that way but what i would say is that
there is a contrast that when you look
at a lot of the
the the research that china is keen on
and is supporting and
and is keen to be part of in the uk you
know
china targets quite clearly i mean it
knows what it needs and what it wants
then is what is going to be useful to it
what it lacks at home and i think it is
quite calculating
and it is quite targeted um
and it it sees in an institution like
cambridge
an organization which alludes to all
these ideas of
academic freedom um is
also acting like a commercial entity
and it's very good at taking advantage
of that i i think
that china has been very smart it knows
what it wants out of these relationships
and it goes after it
and i don't i think that sometimes when
i talk about
naivety in academia i don't think a lot
of these institutions fully appreciate
um just how good china is at this
and just how calculating they can be
when there is a piece of research or a
piece of technology
or a relationship that they want to
develop and i
i think that sometimes in these
institutions these colleges they
they don't really know what they're
dealing with well just to push it sorry
just to push back there though
from what you've said it seems it's
particularly what they're looking for
that you've got an understanding of it
and
it'll be pretty easy therefore to deal
with this and just say here the areas of
risk
be careful about those and other areas
engage i mean i think this sounds very
soluble
it should be i think you're right for
you what are the areas of engagement and
what are the areas of risk because as
kerry says a lot of money from
china is inextricably linked to the
chinese
communist party so if that link in and
off itself makes the money
unacceptable compromising where are the
areas in which you can accept chinese
partnership or money or research
i think there are areas that kerry
mentioned like climate change like clean
energy
a lot of areas where there are our
mutual concern
but i would start from a position of
extreme skepticism
when i'm examining some of this proposed
investments and some of these proposed
link-ups i mean don't forget we're we're
dealing with a situation here where
you know it's not a question of will
some of this or could some of this
technology
end up being used for military or
repressive purposes
by law civilian developments
must be used or must be made available
available to the security state
there are several laws which which
mandate this
it's not uh so much will it happen
it has to happen by law and i think i
would start from a position of extreme
skepticism
yes there are areas where we need to
cooperate and yes
universities are businesses that are in
need of of money
um but i would start with a very
skeptical approach but
i do accept as kerry was saying that it
should be
it should be not easy but it shouldn't
be difficult to lay out parameters as to
what
should be allowed and what should not be
allowed but there are at the same time a
lot of gray areas
kerry do you think this is a problem
facing other universities in the uk and
indeed around the world
yeah i mean i think that we as
universities
obviously are going into very uncertain
economic
climate with lots of issues european
students it's not going to be easy for
them to come to the uk because of brexit
that's just a fact
and chinese students are coming in
greater numbers
and you know that is important to
remember i think those chinese students
are coming for
purely educational reasons but it means
that universities are accused of you
know
kind of doing things because they have
so many you know kind of interests from
china
i think it's important to have consensus
though through discussions like this
on areas where it is permissible and
good to engage with china
china is a technical innovator now
technological innovator it's
something like 637 billion us dollars
goes into research development a year
way more than probably the rest of the
world and
it's going to increase seven percent i
think year on year for the next five
years
many of those areas maybe are very big
problems artificial intelligence is a
big big problem
but the quandary is that china is going
to be now producing
for the first time in modern history
really interesting technology that would
probably
help us hugely and so we have to really
think through the cost of saying right
we're not going to deal with you here
it might be very right not to deal with
china for sure i mean i'm not saying we
should but there will be more and more
opportunity costs
and in environment i think china we have
to work with china we have to have
universities work with china and i think
the
final thing i'll say is that some of the
charming brand building that some of our
politicians have been going in you know
about
beating up china and all this stuff i
don't know they obviously haven't
thought through this very deeply because
it's not straightforward i think ian's
right there's areas where we've got to
work there's areas where we can't work
we need an honest transparent debate
with ourselves about where those areas
are
and then i think we'll be okay and
finally ian how much
is down to the british government to do
in terms of whether or not
providing more stem funding so that
china doesn't have to be there
to fill in the gaps on technological
research or in terms of
education about china we hear a lot
about confucius institutes which are
highly controversial but i see very
little else places that young bright
students can go to study
chinese or learn about china if it's not
for with a
chinese sponsored place so you know
maybe should the british government be
doing better on that point
i think they could be doing a lot better
because
we haven't really had okay there's talk
about guidelines for universities
guidelines for
research but i still see a very confused
china policy coming out of this
government it doesn't really
know what it wants this is from
everything from where we want to condemn
we want to talk up talk out politically
but it should be business and
investment as usual well you know i'm
not convinced you can separate that but
you could also extend that
into the university sector we see a lot
of statements
coming out of government about the need
to look more closely
at cooperation and collaboration with
with china
but we don't hear a lot about where
other sources
of funding might come from where other
means of
as you say the example you site of of of
learning
about the chinese language outside of
confucius institutes
so it's not a very joined up policy you
know we do hear a lot about what they
don't want
as kerry said there is a lot of um
a lot of rhetoric comes out
but i wouldn't describe it particularly
as a policy
ian williams and kerry brown thanks for
joining spectator tv
now to read articles like ian williams's
every week you can pick up the issue of
the spectator or get a subscription for
it
you can get 12 weeks off the spectator
for just 12 pounds if you go to
spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer and remember
we'll also throw in that 20 pound amazon
gift voucher
finally is council culture ruining art
after writing a forthright blog about
her views on gender identity
the artist jester wars has been accused
of being a transphobe for years
recently her critics hunted her down and
she was cancelled
and then uncancelled she joins spectator
tv now to tell her story
jess you've been through quite an ordeal
can you start by explaining what
happened
well um i
have been well cancelled and uncanceled
really
by the royal academy lately which was
just
the culmination really of what has been
more or less a two-year witch hunt
um of myself since i've
um wrote a blog post a lengthy blog post
sort of outlining my thoughts on
gender identity ideology how i feel that
impacts feminism how it
um impacts well language how it impacts
free
freedom of expression and all such
things and as an artist how it impacts
me and as a woman of course
and uh and ever since i published that
in 2019 um
i had uh a bit of a anti-fan club who's
been
using anything at their disposal to try
and
hijack any work collaboration that i've
been doing any
any anything at all really like um they
would have preferred if i would just
basically disappear from the face of the
earth i guess
and so this ended in this
extraordinary situation where somebody
found out that
uh the royal academy stocked some of my
merchandise some of my embroidery
patches
um which they have done for more than a
year but they found it out
now because i have a sneaky suspicion
that someone basically
joined my patreon because that was the
only place where i shared this and
literally a day later is when this
online campaign mounted
against me once again tagging all the
places that stock my patches
um saying how can you associate with
this transphobic person
you should be ashamed of yourself yada
yada and then and one of the biggest
accounts was the royal academy
and then on cue within a day i got an
email from them saying that they had
eight complaints um against me from
the general public well it wasn't it was
a group of
embroiderers no less online
who um had basically encouraged their
followers to
to go and complain eight people and they
need to investigate this because they
stand with the lgbtq community
i told them so do i this is a concerted
effort to try and shut me up has been
for a long time and i don't think that
it's a good idea to drag this into the
public
because i could bring many more than
eight people
to explain to them what my position is
and that it isn't
based in hatred that it isn't
anti-trance or any any the of the things
that
these people say and then i didn't hear
back for
another world two days but the day in
between i found out that they
had via social media essentially dumped
me saying
thanking those who brought to their
attention my
misdeeds my misgivings and they will no
longer stop this transphobic artist
um yeah and then and and it was horrific
so
so you first found out through social
media they didn't tell you
they did not they only then got very um
worried i suppose because i also then
went to social media because it just
felt like
what else is my recourse i had done in
the meantime i went to the police
because the
the this kind of bullying campaign that
has been going on for so long
it felt for the better part like there's
nothing much i can do because a lot of
the perpetrators are based in the states
or based on canada and stuff and so
there's not much
what do you do you know um and
but this time it was a woman who is an
embroiderer who was based in london and
i thought okay well there has to be
something it has to be some sort of
recourse went to the police
turns out that it really isn't much of a
recourse
um yeah and it was super frustrating and
then i went to social media
reposted the screenshot of the royal
academy saying this is where we're at
then i left social media because it was
just super depressing
again that something so big had happened
and
um yeah and then i woke up to an inbox
full of
journalists asking to interview me
because it suddenly had gone completely
huge and was it only after the media
attention that the royal academy
apologized to you because they did
apologize in the end but was it only
after the pressure from the public
oh yeah i mean they went completely into
lockdown mode for i think five or six
days i mean
unheard of apparently i spoke to so many
journalists in the meantime
um their press office just shut down
completely any like you know the times
that the the
the first interview and uh janice turner
tried to
contact the press office no like just
they just didn't respond anymore they
went completely silent for five days
do you think it's um i mean you know
it's incredible because there's the head
of the royal academy who apologize to
you so do you think that
the whole thing was just ill thought
through and there was some junior social
media manager maybe got saw the pressure
on social media and just took the
decision or do you think it was actually
a consistent thing that
the organization has thought about i
don't think they thought about this in
fact i don't think
most organizations have thought this
through i think a lot of people think
this is just
the sort of you know because the the
continuous mantras you know don't be on
the wrong side of history
just be kind all this sort of stuff it's
represented as though
people with my view which is i would
posit probably the majority of every
like of of the general public which in
and of itself doesn't mean i'm right
and i'm always happy to be challenged
but i would say that
the way that people try and and uh
present my view as a controversial one
is very deliberate and so i think
a lot of people haven't thought this
through at all because i was in the same
situation two years ago when i still had
a little salon
on the site in soho theater and and the
same thing happened after
i published the blog they um got mounted
with
media social media pressure by you know
keyboard warriors
and they also had never thought about
this so i don't think
i genuinely think that there's a huge
problem in most organizations at this
point because a lot of this ideology has
flooded in from the universities
it's unsupervised because you know like
the older generation kind of things oh
they know better about social media and
all this
and they just go and do their thing you
know and so no i think it was
extremely rush and then speaking to them
on the phone because i did speak to them
even though they didn't speak to the
press anymore
like that because they got really
flustered and went like oh it's gone
mainstream and like oh no
no joke yeah well it has
of course it has let's talk about those
views that you mentioned um
can you tell us what you wrote in your
blog from 2019
well so i mean it's a very long blog
it's like a 5 000 word blog because i've
spent a long time thinking about this
but to encapsulate it's basically um
stating what my views are on
words the meaning of words how i
understand what a woman is that it's an
adult union female that
that it's not an identity it's not
something i believe anyone can identify
as i think you can identify with but
that's a different thing because
you are the sex that you're born in
that's what i've been writing about
and this whole idea that we should
encourage people to just go along with
this mantra trans women are women trans
men are men
it's just not true that's just not true
and um
i've had so many conversations now also
with with
journalists where they try to
put it as though this is an opinion
that's not an opinion that's a
scientific fact i didn't make that up
and
so far i mean sure science also changes
once we know
new things but as far as i'm aware this
is what the state of affairs is i've
been looking long and wide because it
would have made my life much easier
if i would have found scientific proof
for those assertions which there just
isn't and i had
a million conversations so that's what i
put into that block that
it really worries me this thought
policing really worries me
the degrading of language worries me
the the towing the party line as an
artist if i can't explore certain things
that are important to me
why bother making art i don't do it just
for that the deck you're decorative
you know purposes i do it to be able to
sort of work through things that concern
me
and all this kind of stuff so if i can't
do that anymore because immediately i
will be called a bigot or
transphobe or i want all people dead
that just doesn't work so i put all of
that into the
the blog i said i find it increasingly
concerning that
uh the trans rate activism that i've
been witnessing is incredibly sexist
it's very homophobic
and it's really it's really quite
violent when you look at there's like a
there's like a website where this has
been
um uh collected it's called turf as a
slur
dot com and i hadn't even known when i
started looking into all this was what
turf means which is trans-exclusionary
radical feminist and again there's so
many labels
like i'm just jess those are my views
and i felt like i need to make a
position because i come from such a sort
of like liberal arts background and
people suddenly felt all betrayed
by me going hang on a minute this is
i don't this doesn't make sense and
unless you can make it sense for me
this doesn't work for me and i will call
it out so to clarify then do you think
that it is possible for someone to be
trans or you think it's not even
possible for trans are you saying that
essentially that they
are deluded that in believing that they
could be a different gender
well so i don't believe in gender right
so i i
understand that to be transsexuals which
is someone who wishes to present
as though they are the other sex and
most of the times those that i've spoken
to
um who share my views they call
themselves transsexuals not transgender
because again
gender is this idea and this is where my
feminist
background comes in gender is this idea
that there's certain
behaviors that women do and that
men do and so therefore to me that's
really sexist
like if anything i'm a gender
abolitionist i don't you know just
because i'm a woman i shouldn't have to
do certain things just because someone
is a man that shouldn't have to do
certain things where certain things you
know
that's the problem with it so the idea
that you identify as the other gender
what does that even mean other than a
sexist stereotype and i have yet to come
across a coherent
explanation of what that means without
using sexist stereotypes
so i don't think they're deluded sorry i
don't think they're deluded i just think
that um to demand that i see them
because i see this often really
conflated
that i see them as though uh someone
who's born a man
now says he's a woman that i should then
look at that person and go okay are you
a woman i can see how someone would want
to express themselves differently
fine to me but now seeing that this
whole thing has become so
ideological i even struggle with this
whole you need to call me this you need
to call me that
it no i don't need to do that
and i think what's often missed from
this discussions with you as you
mentioned so many journalists have
talked to you
it's actually that you grow up in a
household which is not gender conforming
you write about your father in your blog
from 2019 and you can see pictures of
him
here and he's clearly not what we
typically think
men a man should dress like but he
doesn't identify as transgender himself
he does not no but according to
stonewall he would be
transgender because stonewall's
definition of transgender lumps in
anybody from crossdresser to
the whole you know and and no he doesn't
he just
he he's literally um you know like eddie
isaac used to say those are not close uh
those are not women clothes they're my
clothes
um and and that i find so refreshing
because that is exactly what i would
solute anyone
in doing you know like not adhering to
those sexist stereotypes
you know just wear whatever you want and
do like dress you know
whatever makes you happy but that isn't
what that is
that isn't what we're talking about you
know and so yeah my dad
likes to wear heels and put on makeup
and
nails i don't have nails
my dad yeah he loves doing it he loves
doing it but he he thinks of himself as
a paradise bird
i think he likes to challenge the gender
stereotypes by doing this in particular
also like he likes to walk around like
that in general because he likes the
look of it
but i think there's part of him that
likes to challenge what
you know like i think he quite enjoys
when people look and go what
and the point is that as a man he can do
that without being a woman and as a
woman
you know you might not want to have
nails and big breasts and you can still
be a woman and that's the point isn't it
exactly that's the point yeah and just
you know since this entire ordeal your
um
orders have gone through the roof um you
do embroidery but
some of them are off what you call big
swinging ovaries which in this day and
age people might think it's
transphobic um so do where can viewers
get get their hands on some
oh they're still i mean they have to
have a lot of patience for now you've
got a big waiting list
i've got a big waiting list i've got
i've had to employ people to help me
with this and even with that we have
such a backlog because the demand has
just shot through the roof
i've got someone sitting in my studio
right now fulfilling
orders and then of course there's the
commission because i do commission work
this is what i used to do like the
the merchandise is on the side um that i
could
um subsidize my
um my my art um career so now
it's just gone i've got a waiting list
for commissions i've got
i've sold all my big artworks all my
small stuff so
yeah it's gone yeah on my website and uh
if
anyone wants to know about new artwork
they're going to have to subscribe to my
uh
mailing list or my patreon you know
well i mean clearly people are voting
with them voting with their wallets and
they really have yeah just the walls
thank you very much for joining
spectator tv
now you might be wondering how you can
avoid a fate of being cancelled and
harangued like dresses
well good news for you if you are a
novelist writers these days can hire
so-called
sensitivity readers to read through
their drafts and see if their portrayal
of various
ethnic or gender or religious
backgrounds are offensive
they can then guide the author towards a
more genuine representation
of the issues that the author may not
have lived experienced for
in this week's spectator the author zoe
dubno writes all about this phenomenon
and on the show today i'm joined by sam
leath the spectator's literary editor to
get his take
sam zoe's article is largely about
sensitivity readers
stateside but are they a thing here in
the uk
too well i think they're becoming more
and more of a thing
um i mean you know whenever america
catches a cold we get the sniffles
and i think there's a definite drift
transatlantically i've asked a few
friends
in publishing who you know how much of a
thing it is here
and the answer is yes it is um i mean i
think it's not as
standard for all big publishing houses
to kind of farm things out sensitivity
readers
but lots of writers i've spoken to not
only kind of
very much welcome this they actually
have sought out sensitivity readers
themselves
um why is that well
i think the argument here is i mean
there's a sort of culture war
you know hysterical parody of what a
sensitivity reader is which says that
they're there basically just to censor
anything that's that's not politically
correct gone mad
um and then there's the other end of it
which
i think the experience of writers is
look every writer
checks the stuff he or she doesn't know
from their own experience you know if
you're a science fiction writer
you might consult a scientist with you
know is this
you know improbability drive kind of
plausible within the
terms of the universe we set up or you
know do
oil wells work like this or whatever and
you know so to a certain extent
sensitivity readers
are a sort of you know extension of that
principle
into people who are writing about
different experiences um
i mean i one reply from the writer naomi
alderman which i thought was fascinating
was
she said sensitive relativity readers
are nothing new
when she was writing daniel deronda
which causes a lot about jewish
experience
um george eliot consulted extensively
uh talmudic scholar emmanuel deutsch and
learned the talmud with him
and worked on her hebrew and as a result
i know the ronda was a better book
because she got stuff right um i mean
one of the big
sort of cultural insensitivity rows of
the last couple of years was janine
cummings
coming this american dirt you know which
as you remember was this portrayal of
um mexican migrants to the southern
parts of the united states
and she's a white woman and she got a
lot of trouble for you know cultural
appropriation all restaurant but
one of the details that really stood out
was she she called a mexican child luca
and one of the you know latino critics
said look
you know how's this child been adopted
from hungary
because you know mexican name boys names
don't end with a
um and that's the sort of detail it's
not politically correctness
political correctness gone mad or wokism
to say
you're just gonna look a bit stupid if
you get that sort of detail wrong
so to an extent i think sensitivity
readers are doing
an extension of what any good editor
does which is to help an author
get the very similarity to the novel as
close as possible
um to what to what's right um
it can also be limiting to the author
can't say you know you give the
example of janine cummings there are
also other authors who have had their
books pulled
and rewritten with sensitivity right
readers because
of the social media backlash you know
there was clara drake
who was accused of being a white savior
having a plot line like that in that
in her book and she had to rewrite it
with four different sensitivity
readers so it wasn't just the small
things like that it's also the content
that is getting changed
no well i think this is where it gets
complex
because on the one hand you've got the
basic idea of just
trying to help writers get it as right
as possible on the other you've got a
publishing industry that's increasingly
frightened
of social media backlash particularly
weirdly in the ya world
and so sensitivity reading for them
can be a sort of way of covering the
arse
and i think one of the anxieties
in the industry even among people who
are kind of quite pro-sensitivity
they say well look if you're simply
hiring you know you're a brown person
you're going to do the sensitivity
reading for us because
our entirely white team of editors
aren't
equipped to do it that's actually a kind
of fig leaf
or a sort of small you know it's a way
of outsourcing
your publishing diversity at the
cheapest possible rates
um i think the question of whether
they're going to cause
writers to be more timid or they are
going to impose so-called political
correctness on
on stuff that's going to be a sort of
you know case-by-case issue i mean my
understanding is that when it's done
right
a sensitivity reader works with or is an
editor
and is going to be making you know
recommendations and
highlighting bits to authors rather than
saying you can't use this
you can't say this word you can't
appropriate this character which is the
kind of characteristic
what they might say ah look
just be aware that this is a bit that
might blow up in your face now
an author is entitled in a decent
publisher to say
look actually this is in the mouth of a
particular character and is serving a
particular
purpose you know because as we know you
know the n word is different when ice
cube says it
than when richard spencer says it you
know everything's contextual
in novels you have characters who will
say things that are offensive you'll
have characters who will themselves use
stereotypes
um so an author finally more than simply
someone is hired in to say you know look
for
examples of you know iffy words or
sensitive points an author's going to be
able to make those decisions
with an editor about layers of irony
about whether they're actually trying to
shock or seeking to shock i mean you
know
stick a sensitivity reader you know in
front of a shalom icelander novel and
watch them kind of melt to the floor
but shalom alcindor and his publishers
recognize that what he's doing is
something quite
complex and where he's offending you
know sometimes said you know a gentleman
never is never rude um by accident
you know sometimes authors are being
offensive on purpose and that's fine
and they and their publishers need to
take that decision i mean i think
to some extent publishers are
you know it's an argument about how much
publishers are entitled to take
commercial view on this
now it's the case that you know as a
publisher as a business
we know that more and more social media
backlash can
damage a book sales can damage a
published reputation can do all the
things that publishers don't want to
happen
and so publishers can and probably will
dismayingly be more cowardly
about publishing the shalom icelanders
or publishing the people who
you know like lionel shriver say look
i'm entitled to make up what i like
and i think that's that's a sad thing
but from the point of view of publishers
that's a defensible position
sam from my conversations with my work
millennial friends
a lot of them i feel are now more loathe
to talk about
other people's experiences because they
think that they haven't had that
experience and they're more mindful
about that sort of stuff
you know this idea of white privilege
and as a white person you might not know
what it's like for example for me as a
chinese woman and zoe dubno in her piece
for the arts leads
talks about how there's also a growing
sense more generally in publishing
that writers should stick to writing
what they know about whether
however identity lines you want to split
that down is that something that you've
picked
up as well um i think it's something
that's more
it's sort of more talked about and more
characterized than it really goes on
i mean you know as lana shriver points
out
you know the the reduction of absurdum
of the position that you can't write
about any experience you haven't had is
that fiction ceases to exist
and memoir it replaces it and that's all
we're left with
um you know i don't think there are
realistic signs of people refusing to
write people of the opposite sex or
people refusing to write
characters who have different races or
different class positions or different
experiences from themselves
um i think that it's generally do you do
it well
and do you make a good faith effort to
do it well
um and that maybe is where sensitivity
really come in is sensitivity
reading you know if it's not simply a
way a
cynical way of avoiding you know getting
cancelled
is going to be a way of trying to
improve your book by saying look
i don't know what it's like to be a
young chinese woman
so when i write the young chinese woman
in my book i'll ask cindy
and she'll say no you've got that wrong
and i'll go good my book's improved
and i don't think you know if it's good
enough for george eliot it shouldn't be
good enough for us
sam lee thanks for joining us on
spectator tv and if
viewers you enjoyed what sam had to say
then you can tune into his weekly book
podcast
it's called the book club from the
spectator so just find out wherever you
get your podcast from or a link should
be coming up on screen now
and if you enjoyed this episode of
spectator tv why not subscribe to our
youtube channel for free
so you never miss an episode just click
the subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and the bell icon to make
sure
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week when football will have come
[Applause]
home
[Applause]
[Music]
100